hey everyone I'm Liana Galera from
Entertainment Tonight and I'm joined
right now by Sophie scout today you may
know as Bree from Outlander I am so
excited for season four I read the book
and I think it's my favorite one
how are you teasing to fans Brie's
journey this year Brie's Jenny's a bit
of a roller coaster
season 4 is really where you see Brianna
coming to herself and she's really
becoming a woman now and her in person
she runs into a lot of new faces a lot
of old faces there's a lot of taking
care of everyone around her but at the
same time she also needs some taking
care of herself because a lot happens to
her talk to me a little bit about the
Scottish festival so we actually found
it twice we did it once and then they
decided to make it a lot bigger felt
like a real festival it was wonderful
they had so many dances and things going
around but it was really yeah we had a
lot of fun Richard's always extremely
funny to film with so my mother always
said men and kilts were irresistible she
was right Bree and Rogers relationship
grows stronger this year they do end up
having a more intimate scene together
did you look - Sam a Katrina for any
advice for how to shoot these on set
intimacy scenes get drunk you almost
have to approach it in the way that you
would a kind of action scene you know
it's very choreographed they're not
always as sexy as they look it is very
do this at this point this dangle this
this so you know what has it been like
for you guys to get to work together
even closer this season TEFL no it's
been good I think our characters go on a
very interesting journey both together
and
stealing down a free honor and Roger is
always a tall man even get close when
they argue and I think it's me
I think the relationship was forged and
in such a way and and such dramatic
circumstances was just something
unbreakable between the two of them so
we can't be perfect
[Music]